hello everyone this game was suggested
to me by a subscriber and I'm glad it
was since it's a spectacular game so
Alexa sure of was invited in 1998 too
due to his high rating to play a 10 game
chess match against Vladimir Kramnik and
this would determine the who will be the
next challenger of the Garry Kasparov
for the title and Alexa Shira won this
match convincingly with two wins and
seven draws the last game wasn't even
played so he defeated a lot Mir Kramnik
without losing even even a single game
but he couldn't manage it financially
and so the match against Kasparov never
happened but Shiro and a lot of other
people actually think that chronics roll
championship match against Kasparov
should be considered invalid since Shura
was actually the rightful Challenger
took a spur off but you know it is how
it is and it's it's interesting sure of
actually won I think it was a it was in
March this year he won the MacArthur
Memorial Tournament and it was probably
a great honour for him since both him
and Michael Tao are from Latvia both
were born in Riga and people have often
compared Alec seizure of the Michael
towel as they're both they were both
extremely tactical players and you know
they share a birth place so there
definitely definitely a great guy so
let's see this game this was played in
1990 it's the year Alexis Europe
actually got his Grandmaster title which
is interesting sure who got his
Grandmaster title in 1990 and already in
1994 he was ranked number 2 in the world
so only bested in rating by garry
kasparov himself and this game was
played also in Latvia he's playing
against a player called
yearsI Lipinski and Lipinski was around
2200 rating at the time this game was
played so let's say this game sure is
white and the Lipinski is black we have
E 4 E 5 and of course sure goes for the
King's gambit we have he captures on f4
Knight to f3 and our g5 here we have
Bishop to c4 and now a very old line
that is
well in those days it was considered
good for white but nowadays an
improvement has been found
so we have G for the Moochie Oh gambit
we have castles castling is the Muto
gambit and here we have G captures on f3
so already sacrificing a piece in this
is move v we have Queen captures on f3
Queen to f6 and out he 5 so Queen
captures pawn and Bishop captures on f7
with check and the King captures on f7
so this is move move 8 and the white
already sacrificed to pieces and okay we
have D for trying to sacrifice another
pawn and here allah Pinsky captured this
pawn with the Queen Queen captures on d4
and it was years later that they
discovered the Queen f5 to be the best
move here and after Bishop captures on
f4 Bishop to g7 and maybe c3 defending
this d4 pawn Knight to f6 and you know
what doesn't really have anything here
black is much better but after this
Queen to d4 I mean after this d4 move
Lipinsky captured a queen capture 74
with check and here we have Bishop to e3
by Alexei so of course the pawn cannot
capture the bishop as its pinned and if
the Queen captures Bishop black simply
loses the Queen the bone is still pinned
so after Bishop to e3 Lipinsky tried a
Queen to f6 and here we have Bishop
captures on f4 we have King t e8 Knight
to c3 we have a knight to c6 and now of
course Knight to d5 attacking the Queen
Lipinsky goes Queen to g6 and here we
have rook 81 with check we have King to
d8 sorry
we have Bishop to e7 if black would try
King to d8 then simply Bishop captures
and c7 is a instant checkmate so after
rook 81 of things we tried Bishop to e7
and here we have a spectacular
spectacular move by Alexis here of he
plays Bishop to d6 and this is I mean
this is this is crushing there is no
move black can make the
would that would do anything for him the
thread is extremely powerful its Queen
to f8 checkmate and well black and try a
lot of things here but none of them work
probably the best thing to do here is
Knight to f6 to stop checkmate but this
loses a piece here on e7 and very soon
the game so Lipinski tried kink to d8
and here well there are a lot of things
white can do for example he can simply
play Bishop to c7 Czech and after King
to e8 repeat this move Queen to f8
checkmate but sure of actually in this
position finds an even better checkmate
he plays between two f8 and well I was
black gonna do a lap in ski the decided
to capture the Queen Bishop captures on
f8 and simply Bishop captures and c7
with checkmate so a beautiful beautiful
move and even if after Queen to f8
Lipinsky decided not to capture Shiraz
Queen and play something like for
example 28 then again Bishop captures in
c7 is checkmate so something like a
smothered smothered mate with a bishop
so this isn't what happened the Queen
sacrifice was accepted and after this
Bishop to g7 and this beautiful 17 move
miniature was created by Alexis sheriff
so yeah definitely
definitely a beautiful game and I'm sure
he was very glad to win South Memorial
this year as well they were they were
countrymen so yeah this is the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and thank for
suggesting such a wonderful game as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and that's it thank you all
for watching and I'll see you soon